una pancarta un poco de música y un
vídeo para recordar quién era sam vio el
patio cómo murió y en qué circunstancias
hechos que no siempre son evidentes para
estos estudiantes de secundaria
realmente no conocía bien los hechos es
decir no sabían lo que había pasado
porque escuchamos muchas cosas de todas
partes pero yo no sabía lo que había
sucedido los estudiantes fueron
invitados a responder anónimamente a un
cuestionario en línea el objetivo quitar
los tabúes cuáles crees que fueron las
causas que provocaron este atentado
[Música]
antes pensaba que samuel para ti se lo
había buscado de alguna manera pero
ahora lo tengo más claro
un diálogo incentivado por esta
profesora que enseña historia y
geografía cómo se envió el patillo
julián y creo que el año pasado el
homenaje fue apresurado porque no
teníamos instrucciones claras y todos
estábamos un poco aturdidos y todos
necesitábamos tanto alumnos como
profesores tomarnos el tiempo de volver
a lo que había pasado para intercambiar
con los alumnos preguntarles que habían
entendido cómo podemos luchar contra el
terrorismo que es la caricatura dialogar
sobre la libertad de expresión muchos
temas que nos solemos evitar pero que
nos parecía imprescindible revisar
[Música]
el deseo de diálogo es compartido por
todos en esta escuela hoy es taller de
caricaturas
y aquí está el dibujo que hizo que
matarán a mi amigo cabo y sobre esto me
gustaría tener su opinión desde los
atentados de halligen 2015 el dibujante
michaella visita a los estudiantes si
ustedes creen que está llamando idiotas
a los musulmanes
es una religión que no deben matar a la
gente es su esencia es una religión de
paz se posa con cuidado el peligro no
son los más humanos el peligro son los
fundamentalistas y los terroristas y
este es el trabajo de un dibujante
explicar dialogar sobre todos los temas
incluidos los más delicados una forma de
rendir homenaje al profesor asesinado
hace un año